[Musik]
tiefe die straßen komplett leer man hört
tagsüber sehr sehr oft die die
alarmsirenen die luftangriff ankündigen
ja man hört praktisch still
also diese stille schreit richtig
richtig laut dieses
diese die menschen die nicht auf der
straße sind die autos die nicht auf der
straße fahren einfach
eine stadt die komplett
leblos ist weil mittlerweile der krieg
herrscht und das zu sehen ist
ist heftig
[Musik]
es gibt immer noch
lebensmittelgeschäften die offen sind
nicht alle aber es gibt sie tatsächlich
noch man bekommt lebensmittel es geht
momentan relativ gut apotheken sind
ebenfalls geöffnet nicht viele es gibt
sehr sehr lange schlangen außerhalb
dieser apotheken die menschen warten
um medizin zu bekommen das ist
tatsächlich schwieriger geworden
tankstellen in der stadt sind komplett
geschlossen also außerhalb gibt es
tatsächlich einige geöffnet sind das
benzin ist allerdings sehr limitiert in
den letzten wochen gab es zum beispiel
keine milch keine eier seit gestern gibt
es das wieder also
es wird wirklich sehr sehr daran
gearbeitet dass das das essen weiterhin
die hauptstadt kommt und momentan ist
die die südliche straße in die
hauptstadt
weiterhin geöffnet das bedeutet
lebensmittel können immer noch relativ
gut wie hauptstadt gelangen auf der
anderen seite gibt es natürlich extreme
verkehrsstaus man steht teilweise
stundenlang an kontrollpunkten
jegliche dokumente werden würden
[Musik]
also es gibt eine ausgangssperre in kiew
acht uhr abends nach acht uhr abends
dürfen die menschen nicht mehr auf die
straße
ebenfalls werden überall kontrollpunkte
aufgebaut sandsäcke werden gefüllt
barrikaden werden errichtet die
komplette stadt ist voll mit soldaten
die an jeder ecke ja aufpassen die alle
menschen kontrollieren handys werden
überprüft
nach whatsup nachrichten werden gelesen
fotos werden angebot ist in handys ein
ein soldat erzählte mir dass tatsächlich
keine privatsphäre mehr gibt sondern
dass die soldaten praktisches recht
haben wirklich jeden menschen zu
kontrollieren
es gibt diese riesige angst vor
russischen saboteuren die er tatsächlich
auch schon in die in die stadt tief
eingedrungen sind und zurück
zurück geschoben wurde
[Musik]
gestern war ich zum beispiel ihr penis
in nordwestlicher stadtteil von ifun ein
vor ort sozusagen das dauert ungefähr 20
minuten von der hauptstadt das ist vom
hauptstadt zentrum das heißt es ist
schon sehr in der nähe dort habe ich mit
menschen gesprochen die evakuiert wurden
die muss man über diese eingestürzte
brücke fliehen die brücke dir von
demografen der demokratischen militär
gesprengt wurde um es den russen zu
erschweren in die stadt zu kommen
gleichzeitig macht das das ist schwierig
für die menschen über diese brücke zu
fliehen ich hatte gestern mit einer frau
gesprochen hieß sie die die es geschafft
hat und aber gleichzeitig gesagt hatte
das war eigentlich nur glück viele
andere menschen wurden angeschossen
wurden verletzt viele viele plätze kamen
über die brücke wurden sofort mit einem
krankenwagen abgeholt und medizinisch
versorgt und auch als svetlana geflohen
ist meinte sie kam es wieder zu
zuschüssen von den russischen soldaten
sie war völlig in angst und sagte auch
sie möchte keinen tag länger kein moment
länger ja in der ukraine bleiben in
ihrer heimat die sie eigentlich sehr
liebt und wo sie sich in schöne wohnung
gekauft hat wo sie einen job hat das ist
jetzt genau das leben was sie verlassen
wird
[Musik]
es ist tatsächlich sehr sehr schlimm vor
allen dingen jetzt in den vororten von
sookie dass wir dort gesehen haben diese
heftigen heftigen kämpfe und wie vielen
menschen die schon ums leben gekommen
sind und zu sehen wie die russen weiter
vordringen ist natürlich extrem
bedrohlich und viele menschen sehen
tatsächlich keine keine zukunft momentan
die meisten menschen sagen natürlich sie
wollen das land jetzt kurzzeitig
verlassen und hoffen dass sie natürlich
wieder zurückkehren können ihren in ihre
heimat zurück zu ihren jobs ihren
häusern ihren ja ihren nachbarschaften
ihren freunden
gleichzeitig ist dass in vielen teilen
des landes nicht mehr möglich
die stimmung hier ist glaube ich eine
mischung zwischen kampfgeist
und anspannung also
wirklich jeder der sagt er oder sie
möchte kämpfen
und jeder der hoch motiviert ist
wirklich die die russen zu besiegen ist
gleichzeitig auch sehr angespannt nervös
und viele sagen auch sie wollen bleiben
weil sie für ihr land kämpfen wollen und
sagen dass aber auch mit einer gewissen
erkenntnis dass es tatsächlich schief
gehen könnte das natürlich ist nicht
garantiert ist dass man ja dass man das
überlebt
[Musik]